james what's up how can i help my wife
and i we have a three-year-old and a
one-year-old
one-year-old boy and they're both embryo
adoptions my wife was able to carry them
but they really don't have anything to
do with us
so my question is hey hold on hold on
hold on they have
everything to do with y'all okay i i
i do get that i just don't know i guess
the proper way to say i just want to
make sure i got my point across
okay yeah you got it you got it they're
not your
is it biological is it your sperm or is
it
is it fertilized eggs
neither of us okay gotcha okay
so you adopted fertilized embryos and
then you had
you got two kids there you go yes she
carried on boat
but we just got embryos from the
hospital
okay very cool so my question is
we we have every intention of telling
them but we need to know age-appropriate
maybe some unique ways i've heard of
maybe possible books that
help with that like kids books even sure
so but we need help along the way of
when and how and
and not to make it seem awkward you know
yeah you betcha man thank you so much
for having that heart
good for you um you just told me the
ages and i missed him three in one is
that right
that is correct okay so
with your three-year-old and it happens
way quicker than you think it's going to
man
because it i was super caught off guard
they will begin
exploring their own bodies and
whatever words you guys use to decide to
call body parts and things right
one of those important goals for every
parent is to not make
any part of a human body feel weird
right or feel shameful or feel right and
so i'm backing way up i'm going to get
to your question here
for my grad students we used to make all
the grad students
had to say in unison right you have to
say vagina out loud you have to say
penis out if you can't say that you
can't be a therapist right you can't say
body parts
you can't be fair if you can't say body
parts you can't be a parent that should
be a rule
right and we've got generations of kids
who were ashamed of their body parts
right it led to all kinds of stuff so
that's number one
your three-year-old is probably already
there asking questions
um they will become four and five and
six during this time
they're gonna ask natural questions
where do babies come from
where do i come from that's when you can
in an age-appropriate way
with all of the joy and miracle and
excitement you guys can muster
there are eggs inside of the girl body
right
and then they have sperm in the boy body
and they meet together
and then they make a baby and
we didn't even we were able to have
those in our bodies so we
got some from somebody else and so we
had to put in our body right so it's
very very natural they will not carry
the baggage that you guys
feel they'll just go huh oh
right and so think about this
when you were a kid well i don't know
how old how old are you
uh 39 30. okay sweet so you're 39 so
we're in the same boat here trying to
explain
to us when we were five what an ipad is
would have sounded like the jetsons
right my kids just it was there when
they were born
and the that idea that they're carrying
around this
half like three centimeter piece of
metal and glass that they can talk to
people the other side of the world
and see their faces is not a they don't
carry that
almost every time i look at an ipad i'm
like this is insane
right so they won't carry that same
baggage
as they get older right seven eight nine
ten they will ask
deeper questions and that's when you can
be more open
about hey here's how mommy's body work
here's how daddy's body worked here's
some of the medical challenges we have
and here's what was so neat and like
another
family where it's willing to share you
with us
and you're our baby and you can show
them where babies come from
and the pregnancy pictures and all that
miraculous stuff
and it will be like a whoa as your kid
gets to be
10 11 12 13 14 that's when they'll start
asking questions about
hey do you think my biological parents
exist right are they out there
do you have re do you have contact with
them do you know who they are
um we have like names and information
but they're
as of right now last we heard they
didn't want contacted or reached out to
so okay so what i expect what we've seen
over the last five to ten years james
and what i expect is to accelerate is
with 23 and me
with um the internet basically
man there's br there's very few quote
unquote closed adoptions anymore
kids want to know where they're from and
they want to know who they're from
and now that we've got genetic stuff for
medical things they want to know
um what might i expect down the road
medically speak there's all kinds of
things there right
and so um i would expect that and by you
time you get to those conversations
hopefully you will have an openness in
your house
a and a where your kids will come to you
for things
they know you will never shy away from a
hard conversation whether it's a body
part conversation or a sex conversation
or a
racism or politics conversation whatever
that looks like you are always going to
be a safe space
that honors them when they ask questions
right and
never makes them feel dumb then when you
get to that 12 and 13 14 and 15 and they
can
understand science a little bit more
when they can start to understand
heritage where am i from legacy those
kind of things
you can honestly and openly discuss that
with them
and if you don't feel comfortable there
are professional counselors who that's
their job
is to have those type of conversations
and bridge those gaps as you mentioned
there are some
great children's literature out there
you can just look at amazon
to find some great children's books up
you know that will walk through these
magical
it gives kids a picture in their mind so
they can see it and go
wow that's me right and
they it will make them feel a part of
something when they see somebody like
them in a book
right that's why like inclusion in
children's literature is so important
when a kid can see
themself in a book and just feel like
that kid looks like me they have hair
like me they have
skin like me they have a face like me in
very much like your situation right um
they got to take a ride and put into
mommy's tummy
and mommy had a big big tummy and then i
was born just like right
and they become part of a narrative they
can see and experience
here's the other thing i don't ever ever
ever want you to ever
ever ever say anything other than i'm
your dad and your mom's your mom
is that cool yeah i don't ever
ever ever want you to feel anything less
than their mom or their dad because you
are
have you carried around stuff in your
heart for a while about that
yeah it's it's yeah kind of difficult
and
and here we're we're trying to have
another kid however
god seems deemed necessary if he does
and one thing we're going through we try
to get back in the same program they
told us it's not likely
and we've heard stories of people saying
you know after their wife's carried a
couple sometimes
things work out and you have your own
and so yeah
we're i think we're still kind of
dealing with that in some areas you know
we had an incident a couple months ago
where she kind of had some things that
she thought might have been a pregnancy
but it ended up being
something different so we were kind of
getting excited and you know
dealing with the whole it didn't happen
again type thing so i don't know it's
just
still some more in there james or
you all staying connected through this
yeah
yeah we we do pretty well okay here's
what i want to tell you and i'm i'm
i'm looking directly into the camera
here i know you can't see me but
um i've been down this road and
me and my wife experienced the pain of
infertility the
challenges with those things very very
differently
and we both thought we were pretty close
and then come to find out whoa we were
experiencing these things
way way differently and
if you just went through yet another
loss and
i'm not talking about loss of a
pregnancy i'm talking about loss of hope
right that begins to weigh on your heart
that weighs on her heart and it just
weighs differently
so i want you guys to make sure you are
hyper hyper proactive
about your relationship how you
communicate to one another how you love
one another
and how you give each other space to
grieve whatever that looks like for each
other
this can be a something that binds you
guys together
but it can be devastating for a couple
okay
and i'm just talking i'm just i've been
there okay yeah
and most importantly if you want to set
your that three-year-old beautiful
little baby and that one-year-old little
baby those
miracles which is what they are
they are what they could what they have
done was it's just unfathomable
oh yeah for sure listen those are your
kids
right and the best thing you can do for
those kids is be
intertwined and connected to the with at
the soul level
with their mom okay
yeah that's number one number two is
never think
of yourself any less they're not a step
away from you they
are every bit of part of your soul
brother and you did a brave
brave bold thing by going through the
adoption process
by going through the embryo doctrine
process which comes which comes with
risk
and it comes with hope and there's
nothing more intoxicating in this
in the this this season than hope and
there's nothing more devastating
than hope right you are their dad
they are your kids and they will be
forever
and your wife is a mom she carried him
to term
she's got two little babies and they are
your kids
you're a dad brother let that sink in
put all that shame
all that hey yeah but but there is no
butts your dad my man
and start today creating a home where
your kids feelings count where their
questions count
where they see you and your wife having
hard conversations together
they see you all hugging together they
see y'all um dealing with hard things
together
model those conversations and then
you're going to create kids that when
the hard conversations come and they
will
that's part of it they're not going to
go running the hills not going to run to
the internet they're going to go running
to the two safest people they know
in the world and that's james that's you
and your wife